bring her back Oh God
or maybe to the night came the night
Queen great warm doesn't know no I think
this is some time is vast we don't get
to see reactions to people finding out
Danny died let's see where we're at
right now we will decide what we do with
our prisons this is Austin - sassy is
gone missin Johnston with a knife in her
heart
let the understudy give him what he
deserves the word about killing my
brother
[Laughter]
King to decide or our queen how is she
still giving advice here's a prisoner
and they're still like oh yeah let's
take this listen in I like to think my
experience has led to some small skill
but maybe the decision about what's best
for everyone should be left Oh democracy
the iron state is not even a person
anymore
[Music]
oh oh weddings births massacres fans
tribes
so how are you taking such a backseat
[Music]
bran daddy's doing it he's not even a
person Syrian the prisoner just called
this Queen on the North Santa star yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
I honestly see some logic behind the
choice for Brandon he's becoming a tree
in the [ __ ] books same time like I
don't want to be a kid taereung it's the
live
[Music]
the nose is free thanks to you but it
was the key it stops don't speak for
ever there you go
what's Western Western us that's why
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
exactly I planned the whole time was to
become king does that you people do all
the work so I could be here in the end I
had no real apology I've had really no
involvement in any of this but sure I am
come across Jamie's story
[Music]
she's gonna finish his story
[Music]
a lot of empty pages left for Jamie to
fill out everybody else is one page only
has six episodes John I'm half hoping
drag on just shows up at the end yeah
it's a way for a lady to come together I
knew what that iron throne was broad run
still standing man that's not the hobbit
and unexpected
[Laughter]
tomorrow
[Music]
she call back to season one
[Music]
look baby you don't deserve him John
[Music]
my girl
[Music]
[Music]
remember when the wildlings River
enemies remember when Jon being the
Targaryen medicine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe looking up some online articles
later on tonight I know what that was it
now that is why specifically that
[Music]
uh well I guess we'll have some thoughts
let's talk about this what was happening
at the end it's just him going with the
wildlings cuz tormented said that he was
gonna take the wildlings to find new
land up north because the watch no
longer resisted so I'm assuming they
were just going off to find new land
together oh yeah that's right they're
there so Aria goes west west west and
they go north north north yeah just see
what's on the up the up sides of the map
gosh yeah
well that was that we are going to do a
season review of this probably tomorrow
or Tuesday perhaps we're just gonna
stick to this episode specifically right
now before we do that I would like to
give a page from the day shout-out to a
lovely lady Rosa Parra who loves this
show she has her own Twitter account and
does her own blogs and movie reviews
Rosa reviews highly check it out she
does a lot of Giveaways and such and she
is such a game of Thrones enthusiast you
deserved a shout out here before we
obviously will dive into some criticisms
about some stuff ladies start engine but
she is the ladies start to our channel
so yeah I know this show has that thing
where it's gonna be near impossible to
completely satisfy fans on how to
conclude this show this is the series
finale a near possible task
most shows don't stick the landing there
are some shows that have for me I can't
help but it's like as much as my brain
wants to be forgiving like oh it had the
impossible task
it really did ultimately feel like a
rather lackluster episode if I'm being
totally honest with myself it did event
of a generation it fell on the floor
like a bunch of lip noodles to me lunch
for sooner yeah you got a lot of things
right that people did not think you
would get R it's funny is always say
like I bet no one's gonna send an iron
throat I would say that as it got
towards here is like maybe John will now
I guess but then did my gosh it's tough
with that original theory John what do
you think I thought this was great I had
everything I wanted it was a perfect end
so I can't imagine any fans being pissed
off honestly I thought it was okay it's
the kind of thing where it's not exactly
the ending to the show that I perhaps
would have wanted it's not doing the
same thing that made me love it in the
first place necessarily however given
that I've had you know season 7a and
season 8 or 7b or whatever this is they
have a uniformity with each other with
that in mind okay for this season of TV
that I did watch rather not it was what
I hoped it would be this is okay some
stuff surprised me some stuff I was like
yeah that makes sense some stuff I was
like I wouldn't have made that choice
but you know I thought it was alright
the thing is every one of these episodes
I sit here and I'm like I'm really
engrossed in the episode most of these
have been really compelling just as
singular episodes that have been really
well crafted and really engrossing it's
weird to watch a show that is doing
everything except the underlying stuff
you really needed to do yeah okay I'm
just gonna be blunt I didn't like a lot
of the way the choices went down here
Jon Snow especially the way they've
handled him this entire season it's like
I'm sure we're gonna do a full season
review but I'm sure some stuff will
bleed over in terms of talking about a
season as a whole I really liked the
idea of after Tyrion officially was like
I'm not siding with you I saw you know
my brother and sister laying there and
then he throws the pin away and he's a
prisoner the way John was communicating
with Tyrion I found myself as a viewer
going I'm gonna give him a pass because
I'm thinking maybe he's just in hardcore
denial but then I've been like looking
over a lot of things Jon has said or
done in this season I'm like there's a
lack of strong like everything he's
saying is it I just wasn't on board the
thought process of things then you even
get to the moment before he kills Danny
which it's like it's leading up to it
and I think I said it right before he
did he's like he's gonna stab her right
like it just seems like it's going down
that path even for Danny in that scene I
was thinking what's she doing after all
that [ __ ] there was one element to that
I like how she has this very specific
perception of what she's doing she
didn't turn into Cersei you know she
didn't turn into look at me I'm the mad
you know she turned into a person who
thought I'm really doing a great deed
and I liked seeing that inside course
we've said this many times I'm sure an
other Game of Thrones seasons probably
would have been able to be the Iron
Throne Queen for a little bit and we've
got a rule to be able to explore a
little bit more of that and then here
you get that it's interesting I kept
getting pulled out of that scene though
once she got close to John because I was
thinking didn't a character bring up
earlier was an aria who said Danny knows
who you really are and you see what she
does I couldn't agree more with aria and
it seems like the writing had completely
forgotten that side I just did not buy
that Danny would be still like rule with
me and be romantic with me I just didn't
like at that point after we had this
giant switch it did not line up for me
even not killing Tyrion on the spot
that's out of kick then those are out of
character it's out of character the
writing is just so inconsistent like
even go full force the episode truly
lost me once drogon did not kill Jon
once did that happen I thought of the
writers thinking about the audience will
be mad at us if we kill Jon we know
drogon we knew that dragon he would
annihilate Jon right right then and
there you would and I don't think the
dragon is going to say you know Daenerys
has really kind of gone off the deep end
there Jon I agree so I'm gonna let you
live yeah no not if you don't have
burned him he would have what happened
or Bree would have the second he saw
John Gray especially with gray worms
yeah I feel like Drogo and burning him
up could have even been satisfying in a
way because it's like he did what he
knew he had to do and he came back one
time to get him to here it's kind of
like a barrack moment but you could have
made it a bigger version of that in
order to you know keep the world from
dance wheel and this convenient
conclusion I guess what they were trying
to do with some of these characters to
me there's a difference when you go
against the ark and you go
to who you were as opposed to coming
full circle you know what I mean like
there's there's no different things when
they say John you're going back to the
Nights Watch and then he goes there's
still a Night's Watch there's a reason
they threw that line in there because
all of us were like they're still a
Night's Watch what a convenient thing
for happening the show so John can live
on grey worm kill it
why would all that MIT is there settings
they set something up with those two and
there's no payoff to it what are they
doing the unsullied are they starting
their own house or something let a
prisoner dictate your diplomatic no yeah
at first I was like well you know it's
Tyrians and they all know that as a kept
going no he's running this now he's like
fully guiding this all decision-making
on everything I mean he is the most
authoritative anybody's political it's
very he's made them as a prisoner and
he's evidently made so many terrible
decisions and he gets to win in the end
by still being handed he should have
died he should have been sent to the
[ __ ] Night's Watch
this is it say to me some of the choices
they make like bran becoming the king
that side to me when I was hearing
Tyrion speak out there were elements of
what he was saying that I said to myself
oh you know what there's actually a lot
of this that makes sense to me
especially because you know you could
see the past present future navigate his
mind here and use it evidently is a good
good dude he doesn't have a hunger for
power yes that's important right there
was that this show did not earn it
though I do not think it earned a brand
took a big backseat for so many things
and seems so inconsequential for so much
and then I don't know where he's the
king I'm like nah the show didn't like
the person in college who does the
littlest work on a group project but
kids the most points on the project play
they get the same amount of points over
really you didn't earn any of this yeah
you weren't involved in anything
he had a whole arc and a whole journey
across the show I mean that is always
the most compelling but that's his art
yeah but he's he's come he's uh being
with all of this knowledge wisdom
insight the whole point of three but
he's off in his own little world he sits
there who's the protector he has no
involvement in the political that's the
whole point of the three-eyed raven and
how come no one raised their hand was
like so there's technically the Starks
end up ruling everything because you
have bran stark is the King here X odds
of the Queen in the noise so they
technically the Starks still end up
rolling all of the Seven Kingdoms six
yeah we wanted it because she's cleaning
the North sure he did have an arc wood
bran becoming King sure he did have an
arc and yadda yadda yadda but in terms
of the show he's kind of been very
absent and for some very important
pivotal moment like that I had close to
no emotion for something like that I was
more just huh okay it's sure I guess
that never bothered me because like most
of our like core the characters we love
are never King was like they're always
people below that rank so it's not
really dissatisfying for me this is
satisfying I wasn't unhappy about it I
actually I don't know I am I think I'm
the lone person who's like yeah I think
that's like whether or not it makes
logical sense with the rules set forth
I'm sure more well thought out in the
books or whatever I don't know
I like bran and I agree with the logic
of like yeah the guy with all the
perspective who doesn't want power is
probably the best person to figure out
what to do with the world so if it was
in character all the three would have
looked at them and said no there's logic
which is an emotional doing experience I
was like oh I wouldn't have been
satisfied of Danny or John and sat on
the throne or Tyrion like nobody seemed
to deserve it and it was the one choice
where I was like I could see that cuz
like Sansa like well I think queen of
the north is awesome for Sansa
Arya doesn't want to throw none of these
other guys like you know like the one
guy gets up to make his case and I like
to shut it down the only person on that
panel at least are left who's gonna
regret like bran was the only one that
seemed like a decent choice and that
could start a new wheel for the world
isn't tyrannical you know true but how
come that whole thing with Jon Snow
being rifle hair
the king because his Targaryen was not
once product yeah that's it's not that's
problems and ran specifically what is
the purpose of that in the car it's
literally in the context of the show to
drive Danny mad because at the end of
the show he ends up still a bastard with
no name at the [ __ ] night's watch
he's back to where he was at the
beginning who cares
serves no purpose except yes they I
guess they weaned out the tyrants thing
I'm trying to understand what the
reasoning behind the choices all the
tyrants are gone now well you needed a
let one tyrant let loose to get rid of
another tyrant and then John swoops in
and then kills that one tyrant that was
his purpose and then Brandon wheels on
in because I'm kidding I did really
nothing new with the night king and I
did nothing smother right Bronn is a
master point are you kidding me the
biggest thief and then you have them
talking about the brothels that's really
what I want in the last episode of Game
of Thrones this is broad sitting there
making jokes about brothels Brienne's
Ark was something to give Jamie a nice
story yeah honest story movie yeah last
speech or a good moment in this episode
that would have been like lack of
conclusion there i protecting his queen
you could say that they Podrick had like
twenty lines this whole season yeah but
hey he got to do it he had a three-way
now he's you know got a high position
yes all doing great in the background
I honestly think they could have earned
the brand stuff what's annoying is he
just kind of took a back seat like on
the flip side I felt like Circe's death
would have been more rewarding if we had
spent more time with firstly these
choices I think could have worked the
man the lack of episodes really hampered
this down we see no reaction to Danny
being dead we literally do time John but
that yeah I was like okay now we're
gonna resolve this it's incredibly
disappointed there's some cool shots and
the video a bunch of different remixes
of that main team never awesome oh yeah
that was great
nice they wrote the book a song of fire
dies finish it but we got it
your car Mart Chicago that's not the
book I wrote here mm-hmm here's the
final two books ending this is what it
is yeah the honesty like this episode
totally lost me once John didn't die
once that happened like DUP show pussied
out yeah that's what's true God just
picked up Daniel absolutely had a
political mentality about the whole
thing
it's like symbolism burned is filled
with things from one specific
perspective or interesting or cool but
that as a whole just don't quite work
out together no LS yeah this is like I
love that Girona in the presence of mind
to melt the Iron Throne almost as if to
sense that like this is a poisonous
thing that just causes harm how do you
know but first time see the nourishes
sat in that chair
even if you want to kill her in that
same scene I felt she should have sound
it's for Bert a whole city just don't
love their characters immediately go sit
in the chair I don't understand the tire
voids Syrian even being like I thought I
was wise yeah yeah I'm like you just
made this whole decision for everybody
of course they're gonna be like you
should be handed together like everyone
in that room in that table would be like
yeah you should be handed the king
completely disregarding you know even
why he's in prison to begin with because
of the countless mistakes you made the
whole entire game of Thrones serious the
Starks have spent trying to get back
together and it answered them separated
with them winning and we all won - I
feel like you would have been rewarding
if this season specifically had a
stronger focal point because there was a
time in the beginning of this show in
the first couple of seasons or whatever
where I belong and I really hope this
show ends where the Starks gonna win
because man they do they suffer and
they're the good ones and then by the
time it got to this these final moments
I was like oh yeah yeah okay I forgot
about that that whole thing I used to
feel about really what the suffix to
pick so grab them and all this other
stuff and they're just like include you
conclude you could checklist and
checklists and checklists yeah I'm not
even criticizing this off of what I felt
like this is how it should have gone
down it's not even that I'm literally
criticizing this based off of what I
just watched a lot of inconsistent yeah
they're slighted or left to hang or his
hand yeah a lot of partial hits and not
a lot of full on him where's the horse
what was the wholesome
drogas just off with Danny's body
somewhere no resolution to that oh yeah
Brandon finally he's eating her is like
a cat you know it's like they say if you
die in a house of the cat eventually
we'll just start eating you that's dogs
- yeah oh wow hey any pet you know I'll
give them this they wrapped it up with
the pending for the show I mean you
can't
oh you can't end it all on a finite note
you do have to end some of these on
she's gonna rule they're gonna do this
that are gonna travel there yeah I'm
like I'm okay with that I'm okay with
some characters having like open-ended
storylines it did wrap it up at least
clean in the north and at least we're
free now
so there's bran made it to the end which
for me is a victory
yes she did I like riding him on ride
about her lover
oh yeah and ghosts made it to the end
John actually looks happy to be there
yeah yeah he looked he looked very
appreciative I think he was happy the
show was a full art did with his hair
and ham with ghosts in holy are two
people subscriber the real rejects throw
that notification bell we'll catch you
guys soon